2023 arrived and Sony have said this is
an important year for PlayStation Gamers
but what does that actually look like
I've compiled every PlayStation
exclusive game I can find that is coming
out in 2023 and Beyond to see firsthand
what we can expect here are the rules if
a game is tied to PlayStation but is
also available on Xbox that is not
allowed so no no and no there are only
two ways to get on this list a full
PlayStation exclusive that means the
game is only playable on PlayStation and
the second way is via a console
exclusive which means the game can
release on PC but not right away on
other consoles of VR devices weird rules
aren't they there's 28 to get through so
let's do this Spider-Man 2 is the game
most of us are desperate to play and
it's also one of the first games to
completely abandon the PS4 Spider-Man 2
is PS5 only after living through the
sublime 2018 game with Sorrows play as
Peter Parker and then a shorter second
game starring Miles Morales released in
2020. it's now time for the two of them
to come together the two Spider-Man have
key differences for Miles he has
electromagnetism and can turn himself
invisible whereas Peter is a bit more
basic Spider-Man 2 has confirmed both
Heroes will be returning and who will
they go up against well we think we
heard the voice of Craven the hunter in
the trailer and of course we saw the
reveal of this guy Venom himself look
out for Spider-Man 2 coming in Autumn
which is September October or November
another game expected this year is Final
Fantasy VII rebirth the ff7 Remake
appeared on the PS4 back in 2020 and
retold the iconic story of cloud and the
Avalanche band of Misfits trying to take
down the Evil shinrak operation that
remake though decided to switch thing
things up and change the story keeping
fans on their toes to a point where
nobody knows what will happen next
rebirth is part two of a nintended
Trilogy coming in Winter 2023 which
means it has to be here in December
again you should make a note of is Rise
of the Ronin a combat focused action RPG
in a completely open world which evolves
over time rise of the Ronin is being
developed by team ninja who previously
made Neo Ninja Gaiden and DOA infusing
all the skills they've learned from
those games to create rise of the Ronin
they are already seven years deep into
development which means we should see
more very soon a 2024 release seems
promising psvr 2 becomes reality on
February 22nd and has a bunch of
exclusive games coming with it the most
eye-catching is Horizon call of the
mountain a standalone Horizon game where
alloy isn't the main character we play
as a disgraced former soldier who
unravel was a new mystery surrounding
the machine animals and dinosaurs in the
world all in the hopes of redeeming
himself and saving his people another
release day exclusive for psvr 2 is the
dark pictures Switchback VR a roller
coaster horror shooter we are strapped
into our seats and must survive until
the end of the ride here's a cool little
gimmick supposedly when the player
blinks or closes their eyes the monsters
will freely move closer to you sounds
terrifying doesn't it and I need to play
it eye tracking is so sophisticated
these days that in another launch game
firewall Ultra eye tracking chooses your
weapon imagine Rainbow Six Siege in VR
firewall Ultra on psvr 2 and PS5 could
be amazing phantavision is making a
comeback on psbr 2 a firework Rhythm
puzzle game psbr2 also has a free
upgrade for Gran Turismo 7 owners
allowing us to play the entire game in
the driving seat literally and owners of
Resident Evil Village will get a free VR
upgrade 4 psvr 2 on release date so you
can live out your fantasies with this
big lady I think that's enough VR for
now
for fans of horror the Silent Hill 2
remake looks amazing one of the most
loved survival horror games out there
first released in 2001 on the PS2 our
character James somehow receives a
letter from his dead wife telling him to
go to Silent Hill what could go wrong
well absolutely everything in fact
expect to be pursued constantly by
Pyramid Head slowly Meandering forward
dragging a sword of unfathomable
proportions this is another one of those
games which will also release on PC
again we are excited to see this year
was Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic another remake of a beloved
game this time from 2003. sadly this
game has had real issues and reportedly
the production cycle has been reset it
remains A PS5 console exclusive but that
may be countless years away a game we
are expecting to see in 2023 is The
long-awaited Last of Us factions too
those who played the original Last of Us
know about the multiplayer survival mode
which pits members of the fireflies
against Hunters for supplies the project
was then disconnected from The Last of
Us Part 2 to become its own game
crafting weapons in life and death
situations and setting traps when
outmanned it was a phenomenal game years
ago let's hope it keeps that charm Last
of Us factions is coming soon jumping
forward to 2024 and a superhero game
that can rival Spider-Man Marvel's
Wolverine Insomniac are playing things
close to their chest right now but come
the release of Spider-Man 2 we're
expecting more info to drop about the
man with adamantium claws all we've seen
so far is Logan sat at a bar after a
brawl oh and the Keen eyed have noticed
that the Hulk is confirmed to be in the
game all thanks to a number plate on the
wall Marvel fans know their stuff
remember when we looked at a Final
Fantasy game well here's another one
final fantasy 16. as always this Final
Fantasy is an action role-playing game
but for the 16th installment it's a
return to the medieval inspired Fantasy
6 kingdoms house a person able to summon
a god-like being it's been said the team
have been inspired by Game of Thrones
and we could see this Final Fantasy game
going a different direction to most of
the others as also the combat is being
refined by those who created Devil May
Cry Final Fantasy 16 may be an
unmissable game coming in April is
Horizon forbidden West's first DLC
burning Shaws Halo returns as a new
enemy Rises up after the end of the
game's events but this time we are
traveling to California and a
dilapidated La in particular have you
seen cheer a tropical open World
adventure climbing gliding swimming
finding hidden coves and sailing your
boat around this new world Chia also has
a soul-jumping ability to take control
of any animal you see and many objects
too and best of all we have a fully
playable ukulele Tia is coming to PS4
PS5 and PC this year remember project
Eve that game now has a name Stella
blade and it has evolved quite a bit
Stella blade looks to be an
action-adventure RPG with hack and slash
fighting mechanics all set in the
post-apocalypse because nothing says
apocalypse like those threads details
are hard to find but 2023 is confirmed
I'll tell you more when we know more
late last year death stranding 2 was
unveiled with a lengthy CG cinematic the
original game had polarizing effect on
many players as some loved it for its
unique take on being a delivery man and
others just saw a boring walking
simulator where do you stand on that one
death stranding 2 code named DS 2 looks
to continue the story from the first
game with a bit of a time Jump Sam's
hair is now all gray and fragile's body
is now looking younger we'll find out
more when kojima-san says so
fans of Devil May Cry should keep an eye
out for lost soul aside balletic hack
and slash fighting mechanics with sci-fi
platforming and exploration sections the
adventure Stars protagonist Keizer and
his shape-shifting Dragon companion who
can transform into various weapons for
Kaiser to wield some of the boss fights
look amazing and now this is the seventh
year of development it's about time we
saw more about the release in 2023 Grand
blue fantasy relink is coming to PS4 PS5
and PC this year a continuation in the
Gran blue fantasy series of action
role-playing games it was due out last
year but was delayed for extra polish
goodbye volcano high is coming around
June 2023 a humanoid dinosaur in a
coming-of-age story about a non-binary
dinosaur named Fang a game I'm hyped to
see more of is Project the perceiver an
open world RPG set in China we are a
lone swordsman wandering through the
world torn apart by War the setting and
the combat bear resemblance to sakuro
another Eastern with fantasy elements
and specialized melee combat PlayStation
released a seven minute trailer
showcasing the perceiver and that's
where the info just stops we don't have
a year yet we don't know if the
perceiver is coming to any other
platforms either so we gotta wait
show our American story we'll release on
PlayStation 5 PlayStation 4 and PC this
year in showa the United States has
become an unofficial colony of Japan
however a catastrophic incident sees
monsters and zombies popping up all over
the region we play as a Teenage action
movie stunt woman who has mysteriously
been revived from the dead showa
American story looks so strange I can't
wait to see more have you seen Infinity
Nikki the team of developers include
members of the Zelda breath of the wild
team and Debs from genshin Impact an
open world dress-up game let me explain
Nikki requires clothing to create powers
for example to use a UFO to fly we'd
need to find the space suit and then by
donning it we attain that power pretty
great idea isn't it searching the world
for the right attire becomes the core
game Flow right now PS5 and PC are
confirmed with a version made for mobile
with hopefully cross progression a game
from 2021 we're still waiting to hear
from is little devil inside
convaleria is a fast-paced action
shooter that places teamwork and tactics
at the heart of its gameplay players
travel through a unique World in which
Science Fiction and Fantasy intertwine
as we seek to reconstruct Distant
Memories from a long forgotten past
here's a weird one Pacific Drive is a
run-based first-person driving Survival
game your car is your only companion as
you navigate a surreal and anomaly
filled reimagining of the Pacific
Northwest and of course here in January
there is four spoken just about to
release which sees a New Yorker somehow
transported to the world of Appiah as
she develops new powers to survive this
fantasy world we did it 28 games what
are your top three games please let me
know in the comments and if you got this
far you have my respect I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure see ya
foreign
[Music]